people aren't taught that comparing what
we have to their hypothetical
politically politically ideologically
motivated utopia is actually a bad idea
you know because it's it just isn't
difficult to take a look at a system
like our system and say well look at all
the problems it has compared to a
hypothetical system that doesn't have
any problems at all it's like well yeah
man problems there's you know we've
we've taken like 99% of the fish out of
the ocean and and you know the degree to
which our current level of economic
activity is truly sustainable without
alteration is at least debatable even
though I don't think it's nearly as
terrible as people make out make it out
to be but I don't think it's disputable
that our current socio-economic
structures are the most productive and
the most free structures that have ever
been produced by people anywhere in the
world and one of the things you can say
about capitalism and free enterprise and
and the Western stress on individuality
is that even though it does produce
inequality a all systems produce
inequality and and without any real
distinction between the right and the
left by the wake because it's a new book
called the great leveler by Walter
Scheib Dell who I'm going to be talking
to later this month he did an analysis
empirical analysis trying to figure out
if you if you grouped government's by
right-wing philosophy say or by
left-wing philosophy and then you
calculated inequality coefficient would
the left-wing organizations be
characterized by reduced inequality and
the answer was no there's no evidence
that they are and what that points to
and this is something very fundamental
it's even it's far more fundamental than
than political is that inequality is the
rule in cooperative / competitive
organizations
you can't positive value without
producing a hierarchy right because you
positive value say this is worth doing
everyone says yeah this is worth doing
well then what happens automatically is
that it turns out that some people are
better at doing it than other people no
matter what it is I'm gonna get better
and better at it like the way I don't
respond
- and then they start getting better at
it so the problem is is that without you
with if you're gonna positive value
which you have to do if you're gonna act
and immediately you create a hierarchy
and you also build into the value claim
the claim that a is better than B you
also build into that the idea that if a
is better than B then people who are
doing better at a should be
differentially rewarded compared to
people who who aren't there's no way
around that if you're gonna play the
game and so in it you're stuck with
inequality but there isn't any evidence
that that social engineering policies
are really very good at dispensing with
inequality which is a fundamental
political problem and no one really
knows what to do about it but
criticizing the entire society is I mean
the thing about the West and this is
increasingly true all over the world is
that it's generating our approach
generates a tremendous amount of wealth
forever I mean it even happened in China
you know despite their exceptionally
totalitarian leanings and so you what
happens with the lefties is that they
say well inequality is a consequence of
the West and the consequence of
capitalism which is palpably false claim
and say well because it produces
inequality then it's a corrupt system
it's like no every system produces
inequality but hardly any also produce
wealth